[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen rallye fällt
heute möchte ich euch zeigen wie man
hefe selbst herstellen das heißt wie
hefe wasser ansetzen
jetzt fragt ihr euch wahrscheinlich
warum sollte man dann hilfe überhaupt
ansätzen hefe ist so gut wie das
günstigste produkt was man in so wachse
kommen kann
dennoch finde ich ja das hat viele
vorteile die gfs selber herzustellen
ihr kennt es wahrscheinlich eher tätige
beck gegessen und danach fühlt ihr euch
vielleicht nicht besonders gut bei
meiner mama ist zum beispiel so viel
liegt pro tag für die piste alles und
hefegebäck sowieso genauso wie ich nur
vertrag ist die hilfe besser als meine
mama deswegen macht mir das nicht so
viel aus bei meiner mama weiß es besser
wenn sie heben was auch selbst als die
häfele produziert und eben nicht auf die
industrielle heese zurückgreift aber
hier ist es so je weniger hefe ihr
benutzt wieder ein rezept um so länger
ist die gehzeit das heißt wenn ich mal
ganz schnell was zu brechen möchte einen
laptop zum beispiel dann kann ich auch
500 gramm mehl auch gerne mal in würfel
hefe nehmen
klar hat man dann in höheren hefe
geschmack mir persönlich macht doch
nicht so viel aus aber meine mama zum
beispiel wartet nicht so gar nicht gerne
ihr seid meine mama sollte dann ein
bisschen weniger hilfe nehmen und dafür
den teig dann aber länger als eine
stunde aufgehen lassen
bei den roten ist dass man die hilfe
geht gerne etwas länger aufgehen lässt
man kann sich viel weniger hefe
verwenden
und ich weiß auch ganz früher da wurde
auch noch weniger hilfe genommen
die zeige wurden viel länger zum gehen
stehen gelassen und die waren wirklich
sehr viel verträglicher
heutzutage muss alles immer schneller
gehen die industrie hat immer keine zeit
fürs geld das heißt man in vielen hilfe
hat wenig gehzeit und die brote im
dadurch ein bisschen weniger verträglich
heute zeige ich es daher wie man die
jesus selbst herstellen kann
das ist wirklich super einfach glaubt
nicht zu fassen wie er benötigt und mit
sicherheit habt ihr sie auch alle zu
hause und dann habt ihr eure eigenen
hefe das heißt euer eigenes wasser
könnte jederzeit um was zu bereiten oder
auch mal pizza zubereiten
theoretisch könnte sie auch einen spox
zubereiten aber dazu sage ich euch
später nochmal die vorteile von
selbstgemachter hefe sind man verträgt
sie besser das heißt man bekommt keine
verstopfungen wie von industrieller
hätte man weiß auf jeden fall was drin
steckt wenn man hat hier selbst
angesetzt und vor allen dingen ist sie
nicht gebleicht wie industrie hieße dies
nämlich normalerweise brauchen aber wenn
ihr mal die packung öffnet dann seht ihr
das nicht frauen
sondern erhält graubraun grenzen und ich
sage jetzt mal die tut haben für
selbstgemachte hätte braucht sie
wirklich nur 53 ist alles um euch herum
hefe also überall sitzen ja wilden hefen
und bakterien und wie könnt ihr
verwenden das heißt es gibt einfach
pflanzen und nahrungsmittel die
finanziell besser geeignet andere etwas
weniger geeignet und ich nehme jetzt
weiß ganz einfaches diese zutaten für
das hefe wasser brauche ich eine große
flasche mit etwa einem liter füllmenge
50 gramm zucker bei datteln und ein
liter wasser
ich nehme jetzt basteln weil es wirklich
super einfach geht und vor allem habe
ich dachte immer im kühlschrank die
datteln haben von natur aus essig zucker
und vor allem eine griffige oberfläche
ist schon ganz viele pilze und bakterien
vorhanden ist nehmt ihr euch das gefühl
und die drei zutaten und die öffnung
wollte einfach so groß sein dass sie
dafür einfach zu erfüllen jetzt die
datum rein
ich find es egal welcher reihenfolge
dann nehme ich einen treffer
und dann kommt noch das lohnt und das
wasser sollte jetzt nicht zu kalt aber
auch nicht zu viel zeit
ich habe es einfach aus der leitung
rausgelassen also hand warm ist ganz
groß jeden meiste arbeit ist jetzt schon
getan jetzt verschließt sich im deckel
und jetzt kann ich vorsichtig schütteln
damit sich alles gut verbindet und sie
im prinzip muss ich jetzt diese mischung
10 mindestens acht tage etwas stehen
lassen und zweimal am tag schütteln und
währenddessen öffne ich die flasche
immer wieder las die nase im freien und
verschließt sie wieder
jetzt fragt ihr euch wahrscheinlich
warum musik nimmt weil man am tag
schütteln und zwar aus folgendem grund
damit das ganze einfach nicht schimmelt
bewegte und kleine oberflächen die
stimmung einfach nicht und vor allem
aktiviert ist einfach noch mal die hefe
das hängt einfach dran morgens und
abends zum beispiel einfach mal kurz
durchschütteln flasche öffnen wieder
schließen
das ganze geht dann so etwa acht tage
man erkennt dann ob die jede mischung
fertig ist wenn man einfach mal auf
macht und brief und ihr kennt ist
wahrscheinlich alle gefräst noch neutral
aber ihr kennt wahrscheinlich alle
werden zum beispiel absatz mal länger
gestanden haben man riecht ist so
verworren und es ist ja genau der
prozess also dass lamentiert jetzt und
zementieren heißt hier auf der brust ist
das heißt die hefe arbeitet und entsteht
und ich hab jetzt auch schon mal
vorbereitet und zeigt euch mal wie das
ganze nach acht tagen aussieht
hier habe ich jetzt also die acht tage
alte hilfe und er hat vielleicht auch
schon zwischen so einfach die gase
entstehen jetzt ein vorteil ist wenn man
schüttelt einfach ganz vorsichtig öffnen
der schaum steinhof einfach gucken dass
es nicht überläuft und am besten kurz
offen stehen lassen dann rückt wieder
von alleine
jetzt fragt ihr euch wahrscheinlich wie
verwende ich denn diese hilfe jetzt
weiter übrigens erkennen die am geruch
wie gesagt ob sie fertig ist das riecht
und einfachere formen aber trotzdem
appetitlich aus richtung schlecht wie
üblich aus zwecken verträglich auch
wirklich sehr gut für die darmflora
denn während der prozesse entstehen
einfach viele b-vitamine
jetzt fragt ihr euch wie verwende ich
die hefe weiter wenn ihr jetzt zum
beispiel pizza oder brot strecke
ansetzen möchte
nehmt ihr jetzt statt normalem wasser
einfach die taste wasser und ihm ist
natürlich dran denken dass dann etwas
länger gehen muss
das heißt wenn ich heute weiss ich mach
morgen pfizer abend kleinigkeiten den
zeit ansetzen kann ich mir den
kühlschrank stellen und kann dann morgen
zu pizza backen
jetzt fragt ihr euch vielleicht muss ich
denn jedes mal das teewasser wieder neu
ansetzen wenn die susler ist nein das
müsst ihr auf keinen fall
ihr könnt einfach die reste verwenden
wenn jetzt nur noch ein kleines lob
übrig habt das ganze wieder mit wasser
auffüllen wie das frische datteln rein
die alten datteln natürlich raus zucker
wieder rein und dann vermehrt sich das
ganze wieder
wir müssen wahrscheinlich keine acht
parker warten denn man hat ihn schon die
aktivierten hilfe teile mit drin
das betrifft auch den vorgang ein
bisschen das heißt ihr könnt hier die
reste einfach benutzung der fermentation
prozess wird verkürzt auf etwa zwei bis
vier tage
also man muss nicht mehr acht tage
warten sondern hat nur die hälfte oder
auch ein viertel der vorteil ist dass
ganze schmeckt nicht zu sehr nach hefe
und er zeigt ist wirklich super lecker
und natürlich auch sehr bekömmlich
das heißt ich werde es in nächster zeit
einfach froh und auch ein bisschen
respekt damit machen
sitzt am besten heute schon eure hilfe
an dann habt ihr eure hilfe wasser ihr
könnt es trinken einfach noch sehr kühl
stellen
und dann könnt ihr demnächst auch meine
produkte ausprobieren ich wünsche euch
jetzt schon mal ganz viel spaß dabei
hoffe dass euch dieses video gefallen
hat vielleicht hat sie auch noch ein
paar wünsche dann schreibt einfach in
die kommentare
und das rezept könnt ihr nochmal
nachrichten auch wenn ich mir das doch
bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]